[Música]
y en directo hoy nos vamos hasta Ecuador
para conversar sobre el acuerdo inédito
al que ha llegado el gobierno de este
país a cambio de inversión para la
conservación Marina en el archipiélago
de los Galápagos Ecuador llevará a cabo
una reconversión de deuda que le
permitirá reducir sus pasivos y al
tiempo destinar esos recursos a la
conservación de las Islas Galápagos el
gobierno Espera que esta maniobra les
permita ahorrar hasta mil millones de
dólares para andar en este hito
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
Ecuador Gustavo Ortega Gustavo en el
punto ambiental que supone en concreto
este acuerdo a la hora de realizar
proyectos y cuánto del dinero ahorrado
se destinará para las Galápagos
Sí buenas noches Rodrigo tal como tú lo
he dicho es una transacción una de las
mayores transacciones de intercambio de
deuda por conservación de las Islas
Galápagos significa la conservación del
30% de el territorio de la tierra
significa también la conservación de 198
mil kilómetros de franja Marina de las
Islas Galápagos De igual forma también
la conservación de dos mil quinientas
especies de en peligro de extinción
especies migratorias como tiburones
ballenas tortugas tiburones martillos y
especies en peligro de extinción en las
Islas Galápagos significa también 450
millones de dólares para financiamiento
el proyecto de conservación a distintas
organizaciones sociales significa
también pescas sostenible y también
proveer de monitoreo para mantener la
salud de los océanos y también también
el desarrollo de la pesca sostenible con
el consenso de Los Pescadores y
distintas organizaciones sociales se
hace De esta manera también con el
patrocinio del gobierno de los Estados
Unidos que ha dicho que supone también
una conservación la mayor conservación
del mundo esto ha dicho así el banco
interamericano de desarrollo bueno
Gustavo y esta conversión es desde luego
un hito para el gobierno del país que
han declarado al respecto Y qué supone
para las finanzas
pero materia financiera también es una
gran operación se supone que según lo
dicho el gobierno de Ecuador resta 1.630
millones a su deuda externa también ha
dicho que esto permitirá entregar
financiamiento para distintos proyectos
de financiamiento se ha dicho también
que
será una proyección para un ahorro de
mil cien millones de dólares y también
permite crear lo que se refiere a
entrega de financiamiento proyecto de
gestión para la gestión de la reserva
Marina de galáparos De igual forma
también para investigaciones científicas
y económicas y también el el turismo
sostenible la pesca sostenible y la
creación del turismo azul como he dicho
también El Ejecutivo Nacional de igual
forma también esto supone una reducción
para Ecuador para poder liberar así
recursos para los próximos 20 años ha
dicho también que permitirá la el
cuidado el medio ambiente para los
próximos 20 años hasta el año 2035